what would a Kamala Harris
Administration look like if she's you
know if Joe Biden is incapable of
leading at some point you know that's a
concern or if she's actually even
elected Dooley uh what do you think that
Administration she has first of all from
from a again the most important
responsibility that the president has is
to serve as commander-in-chief that is
the sole job that only the president has
that Congress does not weigh in on you
know uh presidential candidates talk a
lot about education and immigration all
these other policies where you can't get
anything done unless you work with
Congress to get them to pass legislation
the foreign policy decisions the
commander-in-chief makes are decisions
that that person alone makes Kamala
Harris is
completely uh unqualified and lacks not
only the knowledge and experience but
the temperament to serve in that
position and what's dangerous about that
is number one she will be manipulated by
the military-industrial complex by
people who have a lot of stars on their
shoulders from the Pentagon who uh
would like to see us continue to be in a
state of War for a number of reasons
rather than to pursue peace and
diplomacy and she would as we've seen
with others in the past she would feel
as though she needs to project strength
it's the most dangerous thing to have a
weak person feel like they need to
project strength and have the US
military at their fingertips to do that
if you could only vote for Joe Biden or
Kamala Harris who would have your vote
oh my gosh I'm not a tough one I guess
no I'm not that's like a ridiculous
hypothesis well I mean it's not that
ridiculous we're kind of in that world
right I would do everything possible
but that's not that's not the question
though you asked the right question a
minute ago uh between the two and she
gave the answer that she won't be voting
for Biden so which means it's anything
but a Biden Kamala because her concern
is Kamala and many people are on the
same page with that commologist doesn't
give Vibes of a VP let alone a you know
command or a chief that's a that's a
scary sight for her to sit there and
negotiating with Putin or G yeah oh my
God I mean that's the first place I go
to I go sit there and say who the most
top 10 biggest power players or leaders
in the world who do you want sitting
there negotiating on your behalf without
you being there with cameras off yeah I
do not want her negotiating on my behalf
I just don't I'll just add one thing to
what you said I think it's important I I
don't believe it's anybody but Joe Biden
I I don't I don't take that approach to
anyone because we have some Republicans
who uh hold the exact same foreign
policies as a Hillary Clinton or a Joe
Biden and so I think that's where it's
important for us as we go through this
process to uh be able to look at each
candidate and not just go off of like
okay Republican good Democrat bad
Democrat good Republican bad because
again we look at the war machine we look
at permanent Washington we see people
who may look a little different may come
from different parties May say slightly
different things but at their core their
message uh they will perpetuate the same
corrupt status quo so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
foreign